without any further ado team too hi my
name is Jay this is Kelly Amy Roberta
and Caitlin and we want to talk about
smog not too long ago this was not that
uncommon what made the difference that
made buildings of today much more green
we believe it was the LEED certification
that gave people a target to shoot for
and we ended up with a lot more green
buildings around the world what's our
problem in school today we think a major
problem is that learning is just
disconnected from students lives face it
the students are bored how can we solve
this problem get real or relevant
empowered active learning when we talk
to middle school students and that's the
age group that we're planning to target
and we say what's important to you
believe it or not they don't say what a
over B is when / x what they say is
things like well it's hard to get out of
bed in the morning how can we take a
problem like this and turn it into a
learning opportunity we really just need
to get real when we do we see things
like this these these students have
designed a bed that actually tips you
out in the morning how do we implement
this program first of all we benchmarks
the best practices there are many groups
out there that are doing great work such
as new view the real world learning
network or this very design workshop and
then we build a prototype program we
take some of these best practices and
really try to make it happen in the
schools and we develop the certification
we figure out what the important
criteria are and we list it out and then
we go viral and I would click that
except that I can
uh vote for us awesome can I get them to
step over for some questions and can I
get team three down here please I I have
no idea what you're trying to do can you
aquick Lee explain that just one
question at a time so we want to do more
project-based learning but it's not just
project-based learning it's
project-based learning where the
students are engaged in a problem in
their own life and they're using design
principles like we've learned here in
this workshop to solve problems in their
own life student initiated look at the
link i can open it for you yeah it's
complicated i wouldn't you fire engine
are you proposing some coracle changing
or access to extracurricular protonation
so and we expect that many schools would
meet that certification by changing
their curriculum but if they wanted to
do it through an after-school program
maybe that's you know it's up to them so
it's sort of setting a goal and letting
everybody figure out how to hit that
goal looking at different models that
incorporate these criteria best practice
is there a way of incorporating
curricular materials it already exists
into into your program that's an
excellent question we believe that a lot
of the current curricular stuff is sort
of a part and parcel of this type of
learning so for example you know one of
the examples that we've talked about in
our group is the kids see that the
baseball field is practically useless in
winter and they realize hey if we put up
some wooden boards and some water and
let it freeze we could turn it into an
ice skating rink that involves
engineering that involves figuring out
the local zoning boards maybe they put a
nice plaque on that where they have to
get a quote you know from Mark Twain
about how do you get people to do your
work for you by painting the fence white
so certainly could include a lot of the
what
normally think of as the common core but
please also be aware that it
incorporates the 21st century what's it
called the first entry 21st century
skills aspects of the Common Core at its
core